[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans si on
parlait sport l'émission quatre étoiles
sur le sport local yvelinois vous
connaissez le menu il y aura comme
d'habitude des analyses des débats et
des duels avec la crème de la crème des
chroniqueurs et les meilleurs
journalistes sportifs chroniqueurs
sportifs du département
aujourd'hui ils sont quatre autour de la
table présentation en musique on
commence à ma droite c'est le alain
ducasse du cyclisme sur piste le marc
veyrat des sports extrêmes
il savoure encore sa deuxième place aux
championnats du monde masters sévissent
encore une fois a affamé de titre sur ce
plateau le capitaine ya dujarrier du
club de vélizy 78 est avec nous sur
cette émission
bonjour alors alain ducasse oui le
cyclisme sur piste
ces boues en tant qu'ancien chef de
cuisine oui pourquoi pas pourquoi pas
bon vous nous ferez les petits pas à la
fin de l'émission
on passe de l'autre côté à musique il a
deux passions dans la vie d'un côté la
bonne cuisine française et ses trésors
gustatifs et de l'autre côté le sport et
notamment le rugby une passion pratique
à versailles le gladiateur pierre
chevallier est avec nous commente
allez-vous pierre force et honneur
ça va très très bien en pleine forme
malgré ce froid glacial mais alors
qu'est ce que vous préférez vous la
bonne cuisine française ou le rugby à
choisir lé devront bien ensemble quand
même pas au même moment mais les deux
vont bien ensemble
petite préférence pour la gastronomie
française créée à la fin d'un match de
rugby
exactement en troisième mi temps on
repasse à ma droite musique c'est le
philippe etchebest 2 cette émission ces
analyses sont aussi raffiné que du
caviar sur un pain de campagne et
n'hésite pas à faire sauter le bouchon
de champagne quand il
avec ses interventions devenu que coach
genlis ex-entraîneur de plaisir est avec
nous dans cette émission est beau ce
soir bonsoir à tous genres super forme
en super forme a oui vous êtes prêts à
faire sauter le bouchon de champagne
il file modération bien sûr avec
modération et surtout il faudrait que tu
as the day we la chaîne face à l'effort
termine à la gauche musique c'est un
petit génie amateurs de sashimi de soupe
miso cet amoureux du japon va
malheureusement nous quitter dans
quelques semaines pour partir enseigner
le sport au pays du soleil levant
mais il est encore avec nous aujourd'hui
pour cette émission donc pas de sushi le
professeur fenech anderson est avec nous
le dira qu'il est temps qu'ils
d'elancourt frédéric pas forme toujours
bon je vous allez nous quitter dans
quelques semaines mais vous êtes encore
là bien présents ce jour toujours en
place toujours en place toujours des
répliques cultes aussi toujours prêt
avant de passer au programme de cette
émission nous allons parler cyclisme on
le pensait à la retraite robert marchand
qui a fêté ses 106 ans en novembre
dernier était de retour le 11 février
sur la piste du vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines un an tout
juste après son record du monde il a
réalisé 16 tours de piste pour une
distance totale de 4000 mètres alors
qu'il ne devait réaliser que 10 tours
initialement on écoute la réaction du
centenaire à la sortie de ce nouvel
exploit au micro de nicolas d'amplis et
vous êtes content de revenir ici mais
entendu je vois incroyable c'est un pont
royal
j'ai déjà vu j'avais peur mais
j'ai une réaction par rapport à ce
retour à la compétition y'a pas un
retour à la compétition c'était plutôt
son jubilé justement son jubilé mais
j'étais présent si je courais je courais
ce jour là et donc c'était plutôt son
jubilé la passation de pouvoir enfin pas
passion de pouvoir mais passation de
passion avec les jeunes donc on a fait
une petite photo avec les plus jeunes
voilà c'était plus c'était vraiment
plutôt symbolique et donc il n'était pas
là pour un record ni pour ni pour se
mettre en avant c'était vrai la classe
juste réalisé 4 mm et bien sûr et je
pense que c'est petit s'arrêter
continuez donc encore et encore je suis
largement capable de taper de taper son
heure sur sur le vélodrome à son rythme
sans aucun souci maintenant les médecins
lui ont demandé de
de mettre un stop et vous pourrez quand
même faire des compétitions peut-être je
sais pas je ne sais pas je suis pas
assez proche de robert pour pour qu on
le sent quand même un petit peu diminué
par rapport à l'année dernière
voilà ça faut pas le
faut pas le cacher on s'en doute plus
fatigués mais mais voilà quand vous
entendez quand vous entendez encore
discuté il a encore l'humour il aime il
est monté sur un vélo il n'y a pas donné
pas de secret et puis c'est toujours
beau de le voir de le voir sur sur ce
sur ce vélodrome et encore et encore
pendant longtemps on espère tiers un mot
sur cette incroyable
robert marchand immense respect pour
pour ce qu'il fait et le vent de
fraîcheur que ça apporte sur le sur la
pratique du sport qui rend vraiment dire
que le sport conserve que ce soit le
vélo ou un autre sport c'est je suis je
suis assez je suis assez épaté
émerveillé par ce type d'image qu'il
soit qu'elles se reproduisent ou pas
qu'ils soient en piste encore quelques
temps effectivement je pense qu'il est à
106 ans maintenant ça commence à marquer
un petit peu mais énorme respect pour ce
qu'il fait ce qu'il représente
je pense que quand les médecins nous
disent qu'il faut qu'ils arrêtent match
enfin moi j'ai peur que le tue en fait
j'ai peur que le fait de lui fait de le
faire arrêter sa passion
ski son moteur tout simplement peut-être
ça peut ça peut avoir un effet l'effet
des mémés faste moi j'aurais plutôt
tendance à dire qu'il faut il faut le
laisser devra quand même à tourner je
sais pas individuellement ce prix je
sais pas où ils vont pas renouveler sa
licence cette année genre il faut qu'il
s'arrête ou pas ce robert marchand ouais
moi je suis admiratif se sont admiratifs
on ne peut le connaître
après médicalement on lui dit stop parce
que forcément les médecins et ce serait
regrettable que les médecins lui donnent
le feu vert et que malheureusement il
lui arrive
l'inévitable donc
ils prennent ils prennent beaucoup de
précautions maintenant je rejoue un
petit peu yann quand c'est certainement
sa façon de vivre sa passion et et c'est
ce qui le tient peut-être aussi
certainement à un super forme encore à
son âge
frédéric vous qui est le professeur est
ce qui peut encore continuer je vais pas
aller à l'encontre des docteurs ses
docteurs ont dit on lui a donné un un
diagnostic et des recommandations à
suivre
vaut mieux se plier aux recommandations
du docteur après hélas en six ans il
fait ce qu'il veut c'est un grand garçon
c'est vrai que rendu à cet âge là il
fait vraiment ce qu'il veut à personne
que lui dira ce qu'il a à faire
rapidement il ya le on dit le sport
conserve pas toutes et à tous l'espoir
je pense que quand on fait de la boxe à
un certain âge ça doit user quand même
plus que ces faits sont là on va passer
maintenant programme de l'émission
aujourd'hui nous allons parler de
handball plaisir s'est incliné de
justesse contre massy est grillé un
joker dans la course à la montée
nous évoquerons également le premier
tournoi de floorball du hockey sont les
pintes a organisé à buc
nous avons développé ces thèmes coup de
projecteur sur la coupe des yvelines de
football match des grands jours ce
dimanche 18 février à plaisir le club
local affronter maul à domicile pour une
place en demi-finale de la coupe des
yvelines les plaisirs oies se sont
imposés 3 buts à 1 grâce à un but de
l'attaquant kevin l'orphelin ya un
doublé sur penalty de mamadou syma quand
le héros du jour on écoute sa réaction
et celle de son entraîneur au micro de
tv 78 de penalty c'est la chance on va
dire ça c'est rentré c'est rentré voilà
c'est un joueur que que revenu au club
ya trois ans et qui cette année marche
très très bien après on peut retenir une
prestation que d'un joueur je pense que
c'est l'ensemble de l'équipe qui a été
très bonne au delà de la prestation du
joueur mamadou assima quand la
prestation collective de l'équipe a
beaucoup plu à l'entraîneur de plaisir
en écoute on fait le boulot c'était
difficile moitié match assez compliqué
on le savait face à une belle équipe de
maule très très beau match plaisant et
on a réussi à gagner donc c'est
important d'aller l'aller en demi finale
la question sur ce thème la coupe des
yvelines est elle une très belle
compétition
oui ou non une très belle j'insiste sur
le très belle non non un petit duel
entre les rugbymans ont commencé hier le
très belle et sûrement important
je considère qu'une coupe quelle qu'elle
soit qu'elles soient départementales
nationales ou internationales
elle donne de l'enjeu un club alors que
ce soit pour le challenge pam pam pour
le pour la coupe des yvelines je trouve
que ça donne un petit peu d'enjeu et
donc un petit peu de un petit peu de
suspense soit un petit peu de dynamisme
à une saison de clubs là en l'occurrence
effectivement c'est à l'échelle du
département medano beau département il a
fait beau c'était un beau match a priori
donc je pense que c'est une bonne
compétition et puis qui sourit à plaisir
donc c'est une bonne chose
genre il a tout dit il à te dire il est
d'accord avec moi et il est d'accord
final parce qu'il l'a dit lui-même en la
coupe des yvelines on va pas minimiser
ce championnat mais il l'a dit lui-même
la coupe des yvelines c'est ça comme des
yvelines championnat désignant la france
orange est dit là pour vous aider
championnat et aller de continuer c'est
vrai combat lors mon cerveau la fonction
de plus le groupe des yvelines
il l'a dit lui-même c'est le challenge
pam pam comme si ça on dit que c'est une
très belle compétition
bon pour moi non non non ça n'est pas
une parce que c'est quand même trop trop
local quattro locales pour que ce soit
vraiment dans une ase une équipe pour
une saison ça fait jouer ça donne un
objectif supplémentaire certes mais la
compétition par elle-même le peux pas te
considérer pour moi comme une très belle
compétition
yann d'accord avec je me sens bien sûr
ça permet pas de garnir la vitrine à
trophées championnat départemental ce
sont des couples loin du titre
les coupes décidées pour le titre mais
c'est pas les vitrines la vitrine la
vitrine ne se remplit pas de couples qui
n'ont pas de valeur
voilà je si ces mêmes principes que la
coupe de france avec des clubs qui se
rend compte avec des valeurs
complètement différente
voilà yayi doit y avoir des grosses
différences de niveau et donc
donc non ça doit bon voilà ça permet de
peut-être de jouer sur un sur des
week-ends où il y aurait moins de matchs
donc voilà ça permet certaines équipes
de pouvoir de pouvoir faire faire des
compétitions sans enchaîner des matches
amicaux faut espérer qu ait pas trop de
blessés sur ce type de match et puis et
puis voilà mais non moi je
aucun intérêt pour moi fouad hammerson
bras on peut donc on va fermer quand
même de garnir la vitrine du but puis ça
mais toujours bien vis-à-vis de
remporter la coupe de france je suis
toujours bien de gagner c'est toujours
ça mais toujours en valeur les efforts
du collectif après et pas n ya pas d
dangereux au delà de peut-être de la
satisfaction d'être le champion du
département vaut mieux être comme on dit
à un gros poisson un petit bocal qu'un
petit poisson dans l'océan comme ça et
ça fait peut-être une étoile sur le
maillot ont peut-être changé pour cette
pierre la formule de cette coupe des
yvelines je rappelle que ça regroupe les
équipes départementales et des équipes
comme versailles par exemple qui joue en
nationale 3 et exclut la compétition
pareil pour lui rappelé idem pour trappe
ce ne sont que les équipes qui évoluent
de d1 à la d5 au niveau district est-ce
qu'il faut élargir encore sa peau
départemental c'est pour rejoindre ce
que disait ce que disait yann c'est que
là dans ces cas là il n'ya pas 7,7 côté
ce côté magie de la coupe de france par
exemple qui oppose différents niveaux et
qui permet aux petits de se frotter aux
gros les visions différentes il peut y
avoir des gros dans un gros écart
peut-être pas aussi gros que lors de la
coupe de france
changer le changer le format
permettre aux gros de ce fonds se frayer
là-dedans est-ce qu'ils accepteront de
le faire aussi est-ce que tu verras ça
d'un bon oeil pas risquer les blessures
pas risquer pas risquer quoi que ce soit
ça peut permettre aussi de faire tourner
l'effectif changer la formule
why not mais ça restera de toute façon
une compétition au stade régional
départemental pas la formule pareil pour
vous n'êtes pas convaincu que cela
coince hollande qui jouent alors suivez
incompris pas tous les tous les clubs
je pense bien puisque avaient tous les
clubs du département mais là non donc je
crois que c'était une mini coupe de
france avec les mêmes insiste glace et
la consolante
mais non non non moi je pense qu'il faut
la laisser parce que justement ça permet
à des équipes des petites équipes entre
guillemets parce que petite équipe c'est
péjoratif mais de pouvoir s'exprimer un
petit peu entraide et de gagner quelque
chose c'est important dans un collectif
et d'un club dans un groupe de gagner
quelque chose
voilà mais là on parle pas de ce que
représente la coupe on ne parle
simplement de gagner et donc c'est le
meilleur moyen pour gagner quelque chose
donc pour moi faut pas changer pendant
le public en tout cas c'est une
compétition qui plaît énormément aux
supporters on regarde cet extrait
enregistré à plaisir lors du dernier
match
[Musique]
il y avait du monde yann oui autant
qu'au vélodrome avec un peu plus de
monde qu'en d'un match en tout cas donc
je vais pas parler en mal mais non c'est
bien ça c'est ça fait plaisir aux gens
et puis ça permet ça permet de se
retrouver autour du sport c'est toujours
une bonne chose
donc c'est un succès plus populaire
quand même chevalier incomplètement cia
peut-être que le foot qui est capable de
faire ça c'est là que vraiment sur une
on va dire belle compétition par
une très belle compétition qui permet de
rassembler du monde quand même
c'est le foot est assez fédérateur ça
permet quand même d'avoir des avoirs
d'une centaine de spectateurs sur un
match somme toute sur le papier anneaux
d'or donc à ce succès populaire ça
prouve peut-être son son intérêt cela il
faisait beau et ce qu'ils disent pas ce
qu'ils avaient mis le budget est
gratuite ça favorise avec modération
on continue sociaux par les sports part
du handball plaisir deuxième se déplacer
sur le terrain de massy à troisième le
dimanche 11 février pour le choc de
cette 12e journée du championnat de
nationale 3 après avoir mené une grande
partie du match à l'extérieur les
yvelinois n'ont pas réussi à conserver
leur avantage et s'incline contre leurs
poursuivants score final 28 à 27
on écoute les réactions forcément déçu
parce que je pense qu'on avait toutes
les armes pour gagner le match brésil
logé au métier dont ils n'ont pas
paniqué quand il était à moins 4 ils
sont revenus petit à petit au score et à
et nous on a acheté des ballons un peu
trop bêtement là où on aura dû attendre
un peu plus travailler un peu plus
autour de leur défense on fait une
entame de match
irréprochable et derrière on donne
beaucoup beaucoup trop de ballons à
l'adversaire
au classement ce résultat permet à massy
de revenir à hauteur des plaisirs ou à
la deuxième place du championnat 28
points chacun une défaite qui pourrait
remettre en cause les espoirs de montée
du promu yvelinois la question sur ce
thème plaisir at il raté le coche dans
la course à la montée
oui ou non non un petit duel entre vous
ferez d'accord personne et il ya du
jarrier yann variées vous commencez non
parce que le championnat est encore est
encore long il ya encore quelques
matches quelques matches à jouer et à la
matière voilà donc il reste encore
quelques matches à jouer il faut savoir
qui vous rencontrer à domicile puisque
là c'était le match extérieur
est-ce qu'ils avaient battus massy quand
ils sont venus à un plaisir un nouvel
voilà ils les ont ils les ont battus
donc pour moi pour moi ils sont à trois
points du leader
il ya encore il ya encore la place pour
la montée maintenant voilà c'est ils
viennent d'être promus
est-ce qu'ils ne pas rester une saison
encore dans sept à ce niveau là pour
pouvoir solidifier les fondations et
puis bien grandir grandir par la suite
parce que là c'est vrai que c'est une
belle c'est une belle deuxième phase est
une belle promotion dans cette danse
dans ce niveau de compétition
frédéric inversa ben non moi je pense
pas est ce qu'ils ont fait ce qu'ils ont
raté le coche c'est vrai qu'ils ont été
plus à l'aise s'ils avaient remporté le
match aller car effectivement et ça les
aurait gardées un peu plus proche du des
plages pour de la place pour la montée
après c'est vrai comme on disait il
vient d'être promu et c'était pas
forcément l'objectif de début de saison
après maintenant ça se passe bien donc
qu'ils essaient de jouer leur chance à
fond et c'est vrai que quand on a pour
objectif de monter perdre des points en
route sur des matches qui sont
vraisemblablement à leur portée c'est
toujours un petit caillou dans la
chaussure quoi gens pour vous ils n'ont
pas raté le coche
non non non non pour moi bien sûr s'il
avait gagné ce serait mieux ça c'est là
c'est la pallice ses frais de calais ça
c'est pas un peu naïve aux études pour
dire ça mais ce serait leur admission
mais c'est vrai quand même que on est à
la moitié de la saison et est donc là
c'est simplement le match retour chacun
gagné chez soi donc après mais la route
est encore longue et des faux pas et
n'aura enora de leur part il aura de la
part de massy est certainement et
surtout aussi s'ils veulent monter de la
part du premier quoi donc rien n'est
fait pour les saints on peut dire que
c'est regrettable par rapport à la
physionomie du match
parce que il avait largement fait
largement il avait la place de passer
mais ici c'est guinée d'un but
ils ont été devant 70% du match et oui
mais c'est à la fin du bal qu'on peut
leur caste rend donc ça se joue jusqu'au
coup de sifflet final un match le leader
saint polois compte une victoire et un
nul
de plus que plaisir pierre chevallier
est-ce que c'est terminé vous première
place donc ça va pas être terminée aussi
reste il reste quand même pas mal de pas
mal de temps je vous rappelle bien c'est
la première place qui permet de monter
et la deuxième place est synonyme de
barrage face à un autre deuxième donc il
faut de toute façon accrocher la
deuxième place
quand on dit raté le coche c'est que ils
ont été devant pendant tout le match et
ils perdent d'un but c'est là où il rate
le coche qui avaient ils ont jamais eu
ils auront peut-être pas de meilleure
occasion de mettre un de mettre un
prétendant à distance c'est là c'est là
où ou pour parler du caillou dans la
chaussure donc évoqué fred c'est un peu
dommage d'avoir de ne pas avoir maîtrisé
ce match là cher
parce que m un point d'écart avec avec
massy aurait peut-être été pas mal quoi
mais voilà ça se rate sajoo 1 point à ce
but là et peut-être qu'ils regretteront
enfin 2 en fin de saison
vous pensez que cette défaite peut
casser une dynamique dans l'équipe il
était un bilan de 8 victoires pour
quatre défaites
seule défaite sur ses trois derniers
mois puisqu'ils ont eu tellement de
succès avant que je ne pense pas que
soit leur première défaite et puis sont
allemandes sur une dynamique de
victoires c'est pas une grosse défaite
non plus c'est pas un coup d'arrêt à
leurs prétentions
c'est pas comme si tout était perdu il
fallait tout recommencer à zéro
je suis alors qu'est-ce qu'on mobilise
des prochains matchs et puis relancer la
machine et ce sera pas dessus comme en
40 jean salon permettra cela permettra
aussi peut-être ne pas refaire les mêmes
erreurs
c'est en gagnant l'expérience avec ce
type de match forcément forcément
lorsque jouer des matches de ce niveau
là puisque c'est l'eau du tableau qui
joue donc les flyers qu'ils ont fait ici
c'est si elle se reproduit l'europe leur
forme peut-être pas et ils vont grandir
et il s'est encore une fois c'est la
première saison il évolue à ce niveau là
donc je trouve que pour une première
saison il joue le jouer haut de tableau
c'est quand même très très bien faut pas
l'oublier
il faut peut-être attendre le prochain
match le 86 prochain ils affronteront
saint polois le leader pour se faire une
idée sur la saison là moi je serai leur
de saint paul je dirais le fait d'avoir
perdu ils vont être remontés comme des
pendules
et ils vont vouloir vouloir et vont
vouloir se rattraper et c'est peut-être
pas le meilleur moment de prendre
plaisir
après cette défaite tout courte défaite
contre massy donc je risquerais être un
beau match et pourquoi pas justement là
sur une motivation supplémentaire pour
mon plaisir pour aller chercher la
première place
du coup on vous dit si vous voulez jouer
à domicile à et
mais ce serait bien qu'on en parle sur
le prochain on va essayer il ya le
conducteur de l'émission c'est vos
thématiques joue une note après cette
large page résultats nous allons passer
à notre coup de projecteur dans notre
coup de projecteur un portrait celui de
mathilde claisse une sportive de 17 ans
elle fait partie des golfeuses
françaises les plus doués de sa
génération pour mettre toutes les
chances de son côté gianni viennoise
intégrer une section sport étude de la
fédération française depuis cinq ans
dans cette classe aménagée au golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
mathilde suit des cours en petits
groupes de quatre élèves sportifs
passent en moyenne cinq heures par jour
loin des greens pour préparer son bac s
l'après midi elle va s'entraîner sur les
terrains pour elle c'est un véritable
plus pour les gouttes
je pense que ça aide beaucoup les filles
qui sont pas une structure comme nous je
sais qu'elles ont beaucoup de mal
surtout en terminale lui qui a le bac
elle c'est vraiment dur de concilier les
deux et nous bah ouais on y arrive bien
grâce à sa savane eu plus de facilités
pour m'entraîner
et progresser de son côté son entraîneur
depuis cinq ans trouve qu'elle a
progressé que la sportive peut rivaliser
avec les meilleurs grâce à ces deux
structures pour atteindre le haut niveau
elles sont obligées d'augmenter la
quantité de l'entraînement et c'est pour
ça que cette structure a été créée un
entraînement intensif sur le plan
graphique dans tous les facteurs de
performance ont à la fois sur la partie
technique sur la dimension physique
donc tout est organisé autour de ça pour
mettre là je la joue dans l'est dans les
meilleures conditions
mathilde envisage maintenant de partir
aux usa dans une faculté pour continuer
à jouer sur les deux tableaux le golf et
les études avec un objectif en tête
participer aux jo de 2024 qui seront
organisés à saint quentin en yvelines la
question sur ce tales doit-on forcément
à passer par une section sport études du
sport études pardon pour devenir un
grand champion
doit-on forcément passer par une section
sport études pour devenir un grand
champion
non je tousse il anime sur la question
est d'accord d'accord personne
responsable bien qu'il ya des sportifs
qui arrivent sans à trans pour étude
après il faut pas oublier non plus que
même si ces pratiques pour pouvoir
pratiquer plus son sport ça reste quand
même ça reste quand même difficile le
sport études à l'ets les deux le le
planning pour les entraînements
couplé avec avec les études trouver le
temps d'étudier correctement tout en
maintenant les performances sur le
terrain c'est pas à la portée de tout le
monde après si si si elle y parvient et
qu'elle arrive à poursuivre son rêve
comme ça c'est tant mieux pour elle et
on peut classer la publicité de de
s'être engagé dans cette voie et d'en
tirer tous d'en tirer profit autant que
possible pierre chevalier prévoir
pourquoi voit on sait pas c'est pas une
obligation de faire du sport études mais
pour connaître bien bien le secteur
golfe là en l'occurrence dont on parle
c'est une très bonne c'est une très
bonne occasion de prévoir la suite une
carrière de sportif a fortiori de haut
niveau et encore plus
de niveau amateur est assez courte et il
faut prévoir la suite et leur permettre
d'avoir une activité quand ils vont
quand ils vont s'arrêter
or le golf ça peut ça peut durer quand
même relativement longtemps
notamment chez les dames y percer et y
faire une grande carrière c'est pas
c'est pas l'apanage de tous et de toutes
mais en tout cas faire faire en même
temps que des séances d'entraînement
pousser un peu d'études ça permet
justement de voir venir et de prévoir
prévoir l'avenir la praye l'après
carrière
c'est assez c'est assez facile et enfin
facile entre guillemets comparable pour
le pour le golf parce que l'activité
physique et la préparation mentale va
assez bien avec une avec une préparation
on va dire scolaire c'est prépare son
bac sur deux ans donc c'est surtout pour
préparer l'avenir et pour préparer la
reconversion de ces athlètes de haut
niveau
ça lui permet quand même de taper la
balle et une vingtaine d'heures par
semaine il ya une jarre y est c'est
considérable pour une ville athlètes
ouais haut niveau mais justement c'est
aussi est-ce que c'est pas trop tôt en
fait ma moi mal à la question que je
pose avec les sports études est ce que
c'est pas trop tôt de forêt a commencé
vers 12-13 ans à peu près et est ce que
quand est ce qu'ils on rate pas quelque
chose sur sa jeunesse est donc un moment
donné on n'est pas un peu lassé de de
toujours pratiqué ce sport et du cou ou
son sport et du coup peut-être passer à
côté de côté d'autres choses et donc
voilà savoir trouver le bon équilibre
s'est passé pas si évident que ça il y a
des athlètes qui sortent des sports
études on va on va on en voirie qui
brille énormément ce moment qui
s'appelle martin fourcade et il ya une
très grosse structure à font romeu est
un très beau sport étude basée sur les
sports sports d'hiver qui sortent
beaucoup de
beaucoup de champions maintenant tous
les champions ne sortent pas de sport
études et et tous les champions et puis
tous ceux qui sont en sport études ne
deviennent pas des champions c'était
aussi ça que je voulais je voulais dire
c'est vrai qu'il faut
c'est il ya du bon il ya du mauvais dans
danser dans ces structures s'est passé
pas toujours c'est pas toujours évident
j'en vois que il ya des structures
nationales comme une secte qui a été
créée en 1975 à sur le bois de vincennes
a permis de sortir de grands champions
il ya eu notamment christine arron et
muriel hurtis tni au cas pour la boxe
amélie mauresmo tsonga monfils pour le
tennis ça permet quand même de créer des
champions ces sports études bien sûr ce
bien sûr ça permet de créer des
champions puisqu'ils sont mis dans les
conditions quand même dire à idées à
l'appui ils s'entraînent de nombreuses
heures par semaine et en plus ils ont la
possibilité de faire les études très
encadrées jusque là on y a quatre élèves
donc il aura quasiment un professeur pro
de peu au fait c'est les conditions
c'est la chance c'est qu'on particulier
c'est une chance mais il ya ne l'a dit
tout ce qui passe par ces structures là
ne sortent pas des grands champions non
plus donc c'est pas une obligation que
c'est vraiment pas une obligation et
parce que brett un grand sportif ça
c'est pour moi c'est une chance c'est
une chance comme on peut pousser
peut-être quelqu'un qui a pas les
qualités vraiment technique ou qui ne
sont pas doués peut-être parce qu'il ya
des gens il ya des sportifs qui sont
tout simplement doué et qu'on pas besoin
de ces structures là pour lui pour
exploser le sport quoi et je me pose
juste une petite question je le hais ce
que ribéry à celui a suivi s'est jamais
passé sans mélange hier vous êtes
d'accord et que je suis d'accord avec
jean et pour compléter sur les baies
ribéry aussi sur en france qui est en
train de changer
j'ai l'impression c'est aussi la culture
et le l'intérêt que l'on porte aux
sports les carrières de sportifs sont
sont depuis récemment on va dire
reconnus on va dire
jusqu'à maintenant le sport c'était un
petit peu là la cinquième roue du
carrosse
il n'y avait pas d'autre salut que
d'avoir une carrière enfin d'abord de
faire des études pour avoir des métiers
additionnel et normaux et là maintenant
l'avènement des sports études et puis le
l'arrivée de nouveaux champions qui se
forment intellectuellement en même temps
qui se forme physiquement ça tend à
donner un petit peu de lettres de
noblesse ou au sport et on peut voir des
sportifs qui font une carrière qui
prépare la suite aussi donc c'est là
aussi où le sport et tu peux avoir un
intérêt
par contre comme le disait jean on n'est
pas forcé finalement d'aller dans une
carrière enfin de faire du sport études
pour avoir une grande carrière il ya
laure manoudou par exemple qui a
commencé à 13 14 ans s'entraînait avec à
philippe lucas là une médaille d'or aux
jo et ateliers stands y ait la même
chose qui a trois médailles d'or aux jo
finalement il n'y a pas besoin de
sport-études c'est le talent c'est le
talent à l'état pur le talent le talent
initial et puis derrière c'est à voir
toutes les conditions pour bien
performer dans le dans son sport ça doit
diviser ça doit être différent selon les
sports d'ailleurs l'intérêt du sport
études
ça c'est pas forcément compatible avec
tous les sports mais en tout cas ils ont
tout les tous les tous les entraîneurs
toutes les structures tous les agrès et
tout le temps pour pouvoir se former
mais effectivement c'est pas un
prérequis
quand on a du talent je te refais la
gymnastique aux agrès où les carrières
sont très très jeune et correspondent à
à une période de sport-études où il faut
être au très haut niveau là c'est
quelque chose qui est très très
important maintenant nous savons que
dans le cyclisme ou la maturité vient
beaucoup plus tard pareil pour le golf
le golf
ben on peut comme tu disais joué très
très très longtemps et dont la maturité
peut aussi voilà il ya des sports qui
sont plus porteurs que d'autres dans le
roller dans la structure sport études
les structures sportives puisqu'il ya au
moins deux une sur bordeaux une sur
nantes sont très importantes pour pour
le pôle france alors que parce que les
carrière s'arrête s'arrêterait très tôt
et voilà pour le pour un pour un
cycliste un cycliste peut vraiment
émergé après 18 20 ans donc du coup ne
pas avoir une formation sport-études
lors de ses années de cadets juniors ya
pas y'a pas besoin quoi genre ça permet
également si de se forger un mental on
est souvent coupée de sa famille de ses
amis
ça permet de devenir champion oui oui
oui ou non
oui ou non parce qu'il y avait peut-être
certaines salles ont fait du bien
d'autres sens et peut-être pas
spécialement de ça peut faire le
contraire ça dépend des personnes encore
une fois il ya là ils ont besoin de ça
il y en a ils vont s'épanouir dans ce
milieu là sa valeur correspond tout à
fait et il y en a un ça va peut-être
justement un frein est un échec par
rapport à la situation et à ces
structures qui sont quand même assez
pesant t il faut le reconnaître parce
que là c'est bien là commençait à 12,1
arrive à 17 ans 17 ans
on sait tous que c'est l'adolescence et
que l bolt taper dans la baballe peut
changer de ballons derrière ça nous va
revenir sur leye pas l'esprit mal placé
fait d'accord personne ça a aidé à
forger un mental de champion non comme
je les gens me c'est vraiment en
fonction des personnalités d un beaucoup
plus sérieux fallait qu anderson le
courage je gagne chaque année ce qui est
intéressant aussi dans le sport études
c'est surtout dans son projet de pouvoir
partir aux etats unis c'est vrai que le
rythme que la ici en france sera très
similaire à ce qu'elle retrouvera à
l'université américaine si elle y
parvient mais ça passera avant tout par
les étudier alors il va avoir un niveau
académique suffisant pour pouvoir être
accepté dans une bonne université
récupérer une bourse après
l'organisation du temps et de
l'entraînement restera le même donc les
études servent à quelque chose
ça dépend du projet des uns et des
autres mais ça sert toujours de toute
façon d'avoir une tête bien pleine
pas revu la fin de ce coup de projecteur
on passe maintenant à notre focus du
jour
dans notre focus un sport encore
confidentiel en france le floorball ce
samedi 17 et dimanche 18 février la
ville de but qui a accueilli le premier
tournoi de cette discipline organisée
dans les yvelines un sport importé tout
droit des pays scandinaves présentation
par l'une des joueuses du club et edge
est ce dû de buts c'est comme vieux quai
sur glace mais sans patins sur la
patinoire comme du hockey sur gazon mais
à l'intérieur bon du coup on est sur
l'équivalent d'un terrain de hand-ball
banque est toujours là à six équipes se
sont affrontées pendant la journée au
gymnase du prêt à saint jean dont
l'équipe locale des jets de but que sur
le terrain les matchs durent trois fois
vingt minutes avec des pauses de cinq
minutes entre chaque tir temps comme une
rencontre de hockey sur glace une
réaction par rapport à ce sport je
pensais que sade et d'afrique du nord
parce qu'ils n'ont pas de glace
maintenant que ça vienne des pays
nordiques et alors qu'ils ont déjà la
glace là j'ai un peu de un peu de mal à
tout comprendre
c'est peut-être trois pays nordiques
zuma et du coup ils ont dit on va aller
à l'intérieur
l'intérieur est ce que c'est votre gazon
il vivait alors c'est pas du budget sur
gazon parce que ce sont les crosses de
hockey sur glace
s'ils m'avaient bien gardé mes chers
amis mais ce qu'ils soient pas patiné je
ne connaissais pas mais je ne veux
j'avoue je ne connaissais pas ce sport
là après ça reste une simple vérité sur
gazon mais question à gaz ou sur glace
sans glace avec cross et salaire salaire
assez technique et dynamique et
entreprises ont l'air de s'éclater comme
des petits fous à buc bon on l'a vu il
ya énormément de similitudes avec le
hockey sur glace la question sur ce
thème ce sport peut-il un jour dépasser
le hockey sur glace en france alors
avant de répondre je vais vous donner
quelques chiffres pour le floorball 300
mille licenciés dans le monde répartis
dans quatre mille clubs en france il ya
mille licenciés dont dans 35 lob sur
treize régions pour le hockey sur glace
il y à 21 milles 468 licenciés + 25 %
depuis avril 2006
122 club et quatre championnats seniors
masculin et un féminin
est-ce qu'on peut arriver aux mêmes
chiffres
oui non vous êtes partagés
j'ai duel entre faire avec intersat des
gens miss à les séparer qu'anderson du
mans qui gagne ça vous non mais je sais
pas je sais pas quel âge on fait ça sera
comme comme spa alors ça y est important
en france en 2002 2002 donc ça reste
quand même assez jeune
après l' avantage qu'ils ont comparé que
le hockey sur glace le hockey sur glace
est arrivé en france en 1891 il a été
testé pour la toute première fois sur le
canal du château de versailles
à l'initiative de pierre de coubertin
après je pense que le gros avantage
qu'ils ont avec ce sport là c'est que
les infrastructures sont gérants pas
suffit d'avoir un gymnase et à tout va
la plupart des municipalités à un
terrain de handball de volley ball un
gymnase couvert de basket-ball aussi
donc je pense que le niveau au niveau
infrastructure sera plus facile à
développer que d'attendre que la
patinoire soit construit je pense pas
que toutes les municipalités soient
prêtes à investir dans une patinoire un
clip de ses patinoires en france et
comparé au nombre de deux gymnases c'est
sur ces deux poids deux mesures gymnase
de saint gilles ne sait ce qu'il doit y
avoir juste sur la commune de paris donc
de ce point de vue là le potentiel est
là après est ce que est ce que ça va
intéresser assez de gens pour poursuivre
un vestiaire ça c'est une autre question
donc pour ça que j'étais partagé
potentiellement c'est réalisable
après en pratique bas va falloir bien
pour voir si ça marche
jean
donc pour moi pour moi ça ça va être dur
parce que c'est à dire c'est mixte entre
finalement le hockey sur glace le hockey
sur gazon
puisque c'est la même grosse bloqué sur
glace et puis c'est sur un sol dur
sauf que c'est à l'intérieur des trains
extérieur donc après c'est simplement
une variante alors de là à ce que ça
prenne et que ça fasse des émules
moi j'y crois pas vraiment
après au niveau des infrastructures oui
elles y sont c'est vrai mais sont déjà
bien bien bien bien remplie ben
justement les disciplines commune entre
guillemets qui pratiquait déjà gymnase
on peut trouver une petite place
voilà tout à fait ça abus qu'ils
auraient ici par exemple voilà abus
qu'ils ont réussi mais c'est très bien
non mais attention puis à de sport mieux
c'est mais c'est vrai que après il faut
de tout il faut de tout et est à mieux
que c'est ça d'être d'être sympa moi
j'accroche pas trop trop mais bon
ouais un bus avec une canne qu'il avait
fallu trouver un autre nom parce que ça
aurait pu s'appeler le ok ok en gymnase
puisque c'est à peu près ça peu près un
mix des deux sur glace ou sur gazon
ça s'appelle le floorball bon après je
pense pas que ce soit ça soit vraiment
un sport un sport qui puisse exploser
toutefois ça permet quand même de jouer
de jouer tout en tout terrain et pendant
toutes les saisons c'est peut-être ça
aussi qui en fait un avantage ça fait
9 pouces qui joue à l'extérieur quand il
fait beau quoi donc
donc c'est vrai que ça sur jusque là
balle et un coup avec une balle à wayne
simmonds pareil a tant séduit aux
questions qu il a la technique puis la
même par rapport aux également aux
questions
j'ai besoin c'est la différence yann
jardy de de matériel aussi de tarifs au
niveau du matériel là par exemple pour
le flambeau on a besoin d'environ 100
euros pour démarrer alors que pour pour
le rien que pour le hockey sur glace
c'est un patin coûte sans moyens entre
130 et 140 euros
une envie ça dans l'axé sera qu'avec les
patins on arrive journée un coup encore
plus cher on avait soulevé le problème
de football américain ou des clubs sont
obligés de s'équiper pour des de fournir
du matériel aux gens qui veulent venir
pratiquer mais bon après enfin moi je
sais que j'adore le matériel et dans le
vélo on n'est pas les premiers à avoir
du matériel qui coûte pas cher donc
c'est pas pour moi le critère financier
n'est pas un n'est pas un critère pour
pour faire du sport quand on quand on
est passionné par parce qu'on part ce
qu'on fait on se donne les moyens
d'obtenir ce que ce que l'on ce que l'on
désire donc moi j'ai un vélo qui vaut de
près d'une voiture donc je peux
difficilement difficilement avoir ce
type de discours contraire quoi c'est
pas parce que quelque chose coûte cher
qu'on va pas on va pas le pratiquer
beaucoup de gens pensent que le golf
coûte cher le gauche n'est pas un sport
qui coûte très très cher
oui un parcours de golf coûte cher mais
quand on leur met à l'heure par rapport
à un cours de tennis
c'est nettement moins cher d'aller faire
d'aller faire un parcours de golf
et puis ensuite un sac et des clubs ce
n'est pas c'est pas non plus lourde
c'est pas non plus leurs deux hors de
prix donc
donc voilà il ya beaucoup de beaucoup
d'à priori danser pour beaucoup de gens
et aujourd'hui c'est vrai que même faire
de la course à pied la course à pied
c'est quelque chose qui coûte très cher
maintenant parce qu'une paire de
chaussures pour aller faire du jogging
ou bien il n'en faut pas une seule paire
il en faut plusieurs pères et ça
commence à devenir des sports qui coûte
qui coûte cher mais je pense pas que ce
soit quelque chose qu'ils doivent
arrêter les gens frédéric pareil c'est
pas un frein forcément le prix ouais
c'est toujours plus facile quand ça
coûte moins cher la barrière entre est
forcément moins élevé je pense que c'est
peut-être pour ça aussi qui prennent des
crosses de hockey c'est plus facile à
trouver que peut-être des crosses de
hockey sur gazon ou autre
une pelle et mme richard et non c'est
vrai que c'est toujours plus facile face
toujours plus facile d'attirer des
nouveaux adhérents faire essayer les
gens parce que c'est moins cher ça peut
pas grand chose que quand ça demande un
investissement initial à s'élever c'est
plus compliqué d'attirer après c est ce
que ça va plaire on n'essaie pas on
n'est pas forcément une nation qu'à une
grosse culture de sports comme le hockey
sur glace hockey sur gazon ou même le
lacrosse condom pouvoir dans les pays
anglo saxons le voir finalement en un
siècle il n'y a que 21 mille licenciés
en hockey sur glace la structure c'est
le zerg glissement la queue pourquoi
est-ce qu'on n'a pas de l'équipe de
france au curling
alors qu'on est le premier pays mondial
au niveau de la pétanque et je vais dire
ce sont deux sports qui se ressemblent
mais on n'a pas de structure on a pas
d'endroit pour pouvoir jouer pour partie
culture ligne et je suis désolé mais moi
le curling j'adore regarder ce sport les
cookies sont faits c'est quelque chose
de il ya une très très grosse maîtrise
technique et là je vous avez rigolé mais
non mais aussi le problème des d'accord
dormir devant la télé c'est quelque
chose que j'ai l'habitude de faire je
vous l'accordé mais c'est vrai que là il
ya un moment où on peut pas enfin si les
fédérations s'ils ne font pas nécessaire
pour que les structures existent on
pourra jamais être brillant on est on
est pas on n'est pas non plus en hockey
sur glace parce que ben 20 202 100
patinoire 200 patineurs 200 patineurs
c'est le nombre de patinoires kia à
montréal voilà il ya juste il n'y a pas
besoin de rêve d'aller plus loin dans la
réflexion
c'est juste pitt c'est juste hallucinant
et aujourd'hui les deux danseurs qui ont
fait la médaille d'argent il ya deux
jours ils vont s'entraîner au canada
parce qu'ils peuvent s'entraîner quand
ils en ont besoin quand ils ont envie
arrêtez de rigoler je l'obtiens vous à
vos chiffres sont très bon juste avant
c'est pour ça que je me surprends à
notre rubrique débats
[Musique]
la france a été traversé par de
nombreuses intempéries depuis le mois de
décembre pluie neige verglas vague de
froid des conditions climatiques qui ont
poussé les instances sportives à rome
reporter des centaines de matchs dans le
département on écoute le vice président
du district et des hymnes de football
aujourd'hui 750 matchs qui sont à jouer
puisque la plupart ne se sont pas joués
n'ont pas été interrompus n'ont pas été
disputé du tout à cause de la neige à
cause de la pluie comme vous disiez et
donc ça c'est une problématique que
notre commission d'organisation des
compétitions sont un peu un casse tête
en ce moment mais bon on va réussir à
l'ours elle exigera peut-être des
arrangements même entre clubs quand ils
s'entendront pour jouer une date
adéquate pour eux bas on leur paie me
permettra de jouer à ce moment là les
seuls matches qui n'ont pas été déplacés
concernés les clubs qui avaient la
possibilité de jouer sur les terrains
synthétiques la question sur ce thème
les clubs doit-il investir dans des
terrains synthétiques
oui non oui non enfin un petit duel
entre vous pierre et anne charrier et je
vois je pense moi je dis non parce que
parce que comme je fais du vélo et qu'on
peut le pratiquer pratiquement tout le
temps y'a pas de données passent aussi
même quand il gèle ben nous on aime les
les cyclistes sur route on dvd j'ai donc
du coup non mais on va dans les bois
avec un vtt et puis et puis voilà donc
c'est vrai que la gym pas tellement le
donc pour moi il n'ya pas besoin
d'investir dans des dents des terrains
dans des terrains synthétiques mais j'ai
manqué sur les clubs de football de
rugby mais j'ai l'impression sera
peut-être un petit peu à contre à
contre-courant et est donc certaine
creux que ils doivent certainement
beaucoup plus à voir là la bonne parole
que moi sur le sujet et donc j'ai passé
je vais passer la main pierre mais je
pense que fred et fred et moi sur l'île
sur les sports respectifs que soit le
football américain le rugby
on a des terrains synthétiques et ça a
clairement changé la physionomie des
saisons s'ils le peuvent
les clubs doivent investir à travers
leur municipalité ou directement c'est
l'investissement de départ est assez est
assez cher mais après ça change la
physionomie de la saison puisqu'on on
est on est dans un dans un pays un peu
avec une météo tempérait certes mais
avec des hivers qui sont rigoureux où de
plus en plus rigoureux donc c'est le
casse tête comme le disait la personne
juste avant le sait le cast et de chaque
hiver avec les journées de report qui
sont reportées aux calendes grecques ou
pas à reporter en fonction des
disponibilités
on a eu un épisode avec une va avec une
dizaine de jours de neige et est
vraiment de grosses quantités de neige
donc là suffisamment grande pour que
même sur terrain synthétique ça puisse
pas se jouer
mais en l'occurrence quand les
conditions sont hivernales sont normales
ça permet justement de maintenir toutes
les journées de ne pas avoir de match
trop de matches du report ou quasiment
pas du tout et après donc c'est juste
une habitude à prendre pour chacun des
sportifs date de s'habituer à
s'entraîner et à jouer dessus c'est un
petit peu différent que sur le gazon
naturel évidemment mais s'ils le peuvent
oui ça permet ça permet en fait
d'alléger un petit peu la gestion des
saisons frederick henderson
vous jouez sur terrain synthétique avec
les templiers d'elancourt tout à fait
merci c'est vrai que le gros avantage de
terrain synthétique c'est justement ils
sont rarement impraticable à part les ai
pu chauffer entre 5 et 10 cm de neige
chacun même en dégageant les lignes
c'est compliqué mais c'est vrai que pour
prévoir les entraînements et structurer
le développement d'une équipe sur toute
une saison
c'est beaucoup plus agréable d'avoir un
terrain synthétique et ne pas être à la
merci des débats des intempéries puisque
c'est celle des phénomènes climatiques
auxquels on est le plus on est le plus
exposé sûr avec la neige comme ça arrive
une fois de temps en temps dans la fois
que ça nous est arrivé c'était en 2013
et c'était pas mêmes et même à cette
époque là on avait pu s'entraîner sur
synthétique donc c'est vrai que c'est
vraiment agréable et puis même même pour
le pour les sportifs
disons pas de machine quand ils font la
machine de leurs vêtements de sport
s'est pas plaint de booth et c'est
beaucoup c'est beaucoup plus agréable et
c'est vrai que plus ces puces et
pratique pour les pour les personnes de
pratiquer plus pratiqueront que c'est
vrai que plus on a deux structures de
qualité plus on attirera les gens et les
poussent à faire du sport rien que de ce
point de vue là c'est je pense que c'est
important d'investir dans ce type
d'équipement jambes de marché dans la
bouche mais moi oui bien sûr je suis
favorable
après c'est plutôt les municipalités il
faudrait essayer de convaincre parce que
c'est quand même un investissement c'est
à peu près je pense à millions c'est un
moyen d'euros ça dépend de sa réforme
est aujourd'hui le terrain synthétique
pour une durée de vie de 10 ans en
quinze ans tout au plus
après l'entretien de 4000 à 20000 euros
pour éviter que l'ebit synthétique
fondre en été ils arrosent plus qu'un
terrain en herbe l'été oui mais après
après yann taux d'occupation bonnaire
qui est ambiante et 10000 euros pour
l'aménager ensuite vingt mille euros
d'entretien par an mais après après il
ya un taux d'occupation qui est illimité
guillaume est quoi ce cirque un terrain
en herbe et bien vous pouvez pas au-delà
de six heures par jour d'utilisation
on va vous dire stop c'est fini les
créneaux où il n'aura plus un
synthétique vous pouvez aller jusqu'à 10
12 heures par jour il y aura pas de
problème donc ça permet aussi puisqu'on
est dans l'évolution du sport
ça permettrait d discipline mineure
devoir de pouvoir pratiquer un petit peu
plus du fait que les municipalités
offrent aux différentes disciplines un
taux d'occupation plus important et
c'est vrai qu'après je rejoue à une
pierre alors ce qu'il disait que c'est
quand même une adaptation aussi à avoir
techniquement mais c'est vrai que pour
l'entraînement c'est l'idéal ça par
contre je dois reconnaître pour l'avoir
pas pour l'avoir fait un plaisir et être
un terrain synthétique
c'est très bien parce que techniquement
c'est plus facile de mettre en place le
jeu pierre ce jean et fred mettre le
doigt sur un point assez important c'est
sur le développement du sport dire que
avec avec un terrain synthétique et qui
est praticable tout le temps on perd
mais aussi la pratique du par exemple du
rugby à terssac par exemple du rugby du
rugby loisir ou du foot loisirs des
franches-montagnes au stade de
porchefontaine le terrain est ouvert
quasiment tout le temps c'est à dire que
ce soit sur des créneaux réservés
comme l'évoqué gens pour le rugby pour
toutes les catégories ou en open pour
les pour les séances de foot du dimanche
matin quand ya pas de match quand il pas
d'entraînement ou de rugby ou de
d'ultimate quand il joue au frisbee par
exemple il est ouvert tout le temps donc
ça permet quand même une pratique
régulière et le développement de
n'importe quel sport qui se pratique sur
un terrain avec un petit peu de recul
par rapport aux discussions qui viennent
de yens 2,7 c'est vrai que quand on voit
des clubs de ligue 1 aujourd'hui
s'équipe de ce type de matériel pour
l'heure à lorient par exemple 14 et top
14 on sait que c'est qu'il ya quelque
chose qui est qu'il ya un intérêt
quelque part maintenant j'ai aussi pu
entendre dire qu'il y avait certaines
blessures qui était un peu différente
sur sur ce type de terrain
inédit ce que c'est un tout petit peu
plus traumatiques c'est vrai que c'est
l'habitude dont je parlais il faut il
céder cd peut-être déblocage de jambes
un petit peu différent et puis du
traumatique du traumatique différentes
celui de média saturn tiers chaussures
il ya un problème c'est que ça quand tu
vois des choses c'est exact au début
lorsque ça s'est vraiment développée et
ses rennes synthétique il y avait un
problème au niveau des chaussures les
chaussures les fameuses saucisses
chaussures à l'âme de soul à qui elle
justement bloquer le pied et donc avec
sas a bloqué le pied et après sa tournée
des questions tout ce que tu es cheville
et genou il y avait d'énormes blessures
notamment faire du rugby - il va dès
lors nos blessures au niveau du rugby à
ce niveau au niveau genoux et les
chevilles dû à ce blocage de pied mais
c'était dû à la chaussure s'était pas dû
il a beaucoup moins aujourd'hui et là
c'est la technique et je prendrai le
côté scientifique qui fait des progrès
c'est à dire on dénombre en être la
septième ou huitième génération de deux
terrains synthétiques désormais en
france et qui ont je pense du en dû
tirer parti de ce qui posait problème
justement un train les chaussures à
travers le la mobilité et le côté
traumatique de certaines premières sur
un terrain très bien généreux en loisir
sur un terrain synthétique c'était il ya
plus d'une quinzaine d'années donc comme
tu dis ça maintenant j'ai aussi entendu
dire qu'il y avait des petits soucis de
alors après je suis les personnes trop
bon trouve bien pensantes ont
certainement eu ce genre d'intervention
des problèmes cancérigène par rapport
aux billes qui qui étaient utilisés etc
voilà ne sait comment est-ce qu'il faut
attendre attendre quoi avant d'installer
à des terrains synthétiques sur toutes
les commissions synthétique à l emploi
quand c'était encore un astre hauteur
c'est les anciennes générations que
c'était la moquette et on aa par des
brûlures on n'a jamais eu de problème la
personne qui a écrit un troisième
michael pousser des ailes
c'est pour ça que j'ai déjà trop bien
pensants c'est vrai qu'au dessus que je
respecte duroux
mais après c'est une question qui mérite
d'être posée mais c'est vrai que
scientifique mais j'avais fait des
études en hollande d'ailleurs en 2016 a
publié dans une grande revue bas coût
final n'y avait aucune différence y
avait aucun risque que c'était
complètement hainaut cutter ou bien
simplement au niveau des hauts niveaux
des plaies au niveau médical il ya eu et
u11 petit rapport au niveau des pl et
les billes
l'ebit surtout dans les plaies et niveau
chirurgicale ils sont centrés très très
avant c'était du sable
ouais mais nous oui mais le souhait mais
fait le l'ebit l'ebit assez sur un gros
problème au niveau chirurgicale et ils
disent que pour pour nettoyer la plaie
c'est très compliqué si loin mais c'est
mieux pour les machines à laver
[Musique]
on termine par des images insolites
après avoir cueilli un match de handball
féminin début février le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines s'est
transformée en un gigantesque circuit ce
vendredi 16 février pour la 8e édition
de la butte âge parti pour cette
première en ile-de-france 250 têtes
brûlées se sont affrontés avec des mini
motos sur un tracé improvisé avec des
barrières innovante de plusieurs mètres
de haut
ce soir là pas de classement mais une
bonne dose de rire accès entre ses fans
de jackie stewart ou steve mcqueen on
écoute les réactions micro de grégory
canale qui avait adopté la nuque longue
pour l'occasion moreira marc casta silva
dos santos seul jonathan
on vient
région de la paris pour les leurs pour
la vie dure et pour la moto à la bagarre
en deux villas et des beats une vitesse
très vite et steve mcqueen est mort jack
istya clara morgane vintage des bagarres
tout ce que tu veux pêche parce que
cette ingérence résume bien la soirée on
est venu là pour s'amuser pour me
connaissent un très bon quoi cet hommage
et vous sentez pas l'honneur quoi c'est
super pas de l'ambiance et voilà c'est
gentillet
c'est cool
[Musique]
hsu sommes affamés motorisée de sortir
ce soir je suis là parce qu'elle est la
lumière une poche pour entrer qu'est-ce
que vous êtes venu chercher ici ce soir
d'abord de l'association est
un peu glaçons parce que le vert il
serait chaud vite alors je précise que
l'abus d'alcool est dangereux pour la
santé
direction par rapport à cet événement
parce que valider ya pas assez de
communication et du coup moi je l'appris
je l'appris le dimanche quand je fais le
vélodrome que ça nous aurait pas vous
retrouvez dans la vidéo
je suis voilà pour la moto parce que je
bois pas d'alcool
évidemment c'est pas moi c'est comme
envers marchand c'est hyper frais
j'enrage c'est très bien mais finalement
il ya que le souligne le cabinet oui
c'était 300 personnes quand même eh bien
oui c'est pour ça il y avait du monde
suivait bien et je pense aussi grossier
et apparemment ça fini à 5 heures du
matin je prends un truc comme ça ça a
été sauvé moto c'est très sympa avec
modération c'est rigolo faire des
commerçants
c'est une compétition c'est pas une
compétition il faut communiquer quoi je
pense qu'il faut inviter plus de monde
que ça avait pas de compétition c'est
les mecs qui étaient là juste pour
s'amuser d'ailleurs c'est la partie de
karting la partie de karting que tu fais
avec venir avec les coppola tout à fait
ces morceaux choisis ouverture le dire
on n'est pas sportif est ce que
finalement ou si ça pouvait se prêter à
ce jeu c'est pas des gens qui aiment la
moto qui aime les courses automobiles
elle est mais attendez combien de gens
vont voir les 24 heures du mans pour
faire la fête et qui ne regarde derrien
delà de la compétition ou alors le grand
prix de france
ou alors le grand prix de france moto et
qui reste au camping et qui voit pas et
qu'ils voient pas de deux motos de mode
de deux minutes de
du grand prix motogp voilà ça fait
partie du ca fait partie du plaisir et
de la et de l'ambiance quand on est
quand on est sur une compétition
est ce que le vélodrome est adapté pour
ce style de rendez vous pierre ah oui
oui oui c'est déjà une grosse boîte de
nuit avec quelques motos au milieu ça
c'est dans les années 80 se fait avec
des rollers à la cdm ou de cd moto je
conseille je trouve ça bon enfant
toujours avec modération ccip c'est
hyper sympa mais bon ça hyper marrant
hellènes réduits à 10 mn de la grogne
est chroniqué dans cette émission la
fumière malheureusement pour cette
émission alors à lui mettre des barres
de pole dance fallait qu'un personne ça
s'y prête ou pas ce vélodrome ça allait
en tout cas ça me rassure un ballon on
voit qu'il ya du cyclisme aussie
charrier il ya également ce style de
rendez vous je lis un peu comme paris
bercy peut être un palais omnisports et
organiser tous types de d'événement
c'est vrai qu'à paris bercy avec le
supermotocross sait plus comment ça
s'appelle le fusible super françois mais
c'est vrai que c'était gelé fait
plusieurs fois et c'est vrai que c'était
très juste et très bien donc si on peut
si on peut reproduire la même chose dans
l'ouest parisien chez nous pour s'en
priver
l'espace du vélodrome n'a pas été même
assez utilisé pour
pour ce truc là je pense qu'il y avait
encore plus sympa à faire parce qu'il ya
des petites rampe à droite à gauche qui
peuvent permettre de faire quelque chose
de plus sain pas encore quand j'ai pensé
après tiens je moteur de revoir l genre
l'année prochaine vous réservez mais
c'est dommage que je sois bien sûr avec
modération toujours c'est la fin de
cette émission se retrouvent le jeudi 8
mars où une nouvelle émission va
terminer par une citation un peu osé de
la légende du football argentin el pibe
et d oro diego maradona arrivée dans la
surface et ne pas pouvoir tirs au but
c'est comme danser avec sa soeur je vous
laisse méditer sur cette phrase à
bientôt sur tv 78 mourir à marcq da
silva dos santos âge
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui